[Music]
on this saturday night the coronavirus
crisis
in hutterite colonies the difficult new
reality facing these tight-knit
communities
we eat together we worship together we
work together
why some of these residents fear getting
treatment
face mask finds what offenders in
alberta's two largest cities will
have to cough up if they don't cover up
a canadian-born hockey player takes a
shot at a long-standing problem
racism is everywhere and we need to
fight
against it a stirring speech as the nhl
restarts and communicating using
a robot having a video call is nothing
like
being with someone when being face to
face won't suffice
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us there are warnings across the country
tonight to stay
vigilant this long weekend many
provinces are seeing an uptick in coven
19 cases
health officials are concerned things
could get worse if canadians get too
relaxed on this holiday weekend
that is often associated with friends
and family getting together or traveling
three provinces reported new numbers
today there are 146 new cases in quebec
and 124 in ontario in saskatchewan there
are 15 new cases health authorities say
nine of them are from multiple hutterite
colonies across the province
across the prairies there is a surge in
cases in several hutterite colonies
it's causing those who live there to
make some major changes in their
day-to-day lives
as global's marnie blunt tells us
residents are fighting
two invisible enemies the virus itself
and the stigma it's causing their small
christian-based communities nestled in
rural areas of canada
they're living rooted in agriculture and
that's basically
just part of our lifestyle is the
tight-knit closeness of our
families and we just support one another
but some hutterite colonies in canada
are facing adversity
in trying to contain coven 19 outbreaks
in recent weeks hundreds of cases have
been reported on colonies
in alberta saskatchewan and manitoba
many linked to local
and intra-provincial travel the
outbreaks are forcing some colonies to
go into lockdown
and implement strict physical distancing
measures
for hutterites we've learned and we're
struggling to
realize that our communal way of life
the way we've
organized our life for 500 years
poses some unique and very specific
risks
in regards to a viral outbreak like
covert 19.
and a lack of understanding those
traditions is causing even more problems
hud rights have experienced legitimate
concerns
regarding stigmatization and cultural
profiling this has ranged from
being turned away at doctor's offices
to being spat on to being sent
out of retail uh outlets and
this has resulted in heteroites
resisting testing it has many members of
hunterite colonies speaking out against
stigma
in manitoba public health officials have
stopped identifying colonies when
reporting on clusters of covid19
a stigma that only hinders our ability
to fight the virus
covet 19 does not discriminate this
virus can affect any one of us
and so it's systems is society that
discriminates
and not the virus itself a key reminder
that kindness can go a long way
in the fight to keep canadians safe
marnie blunt
global news winnipeg in alberta's two
biggest cities
masks are now mandatory in all indoor
public spaces
free disposable masks are being handed
out in calgary and edmonton today
new bylaws require people to wear face
coverings at all times in
any indoor space the public has access
to those include retail and grocery
stores shopping malls
recreation centers churches plus transit
and taxis
in edmonton you could be fined fifty
dollars for not following the rules
in calgary the fine is a hundred dollars
the majority of coven 19 deaths in this
country are linked to long-term care
homes
and a new study at a british columbia
may have uncovered a crucial touch point
in transmission
nadia stewart has more on the commonly
used healthcare device that's at
high risk of being contaminated by the
virus
okay just going to tighten for a minute
there of all the covid 19 touch points
blood pressure cuffs might not have been
high up on the list
but a vancouver coastal health study is
drawing attention to the equipment used
in long-term care homes
identifying contamination on things
staff use
every day some of the medical equipment
that moves from room to room things like
blood pressure cuffs
an electronic medical tablet and a linen
cart were actually found to be
contaminated with the virus causing
covet 19.
researchers focused on three care homes
while they were in the midst of covid 19
outbreaks
89 surfaces were swabbed six samples
tested positive for the virus of the
nine blood pressure cuffs swabbed
four were contaminated researchers say
some care homes have found solutions
beyond even more stringent sanitation
that includes having dedicated equipment
so for people who are known to be
infected with covet 19 for them to have
their own equipment that stays put in
those rooms
and doesn't present a risk to others is
one thing that some of the homes have
taken on as a new step
but measures such as this come at a cost
for things like
blood pressure cuffs you you do have an
option of having one time use but the
cost of that is extraordinary
mike claussen of the bc care providers
association says care home staff will
likely focus on
enhanced cleaning because so many costs
have increased
in the wake of the pandemic as
researchers continue to look at the
surfaces identified as hot spots
clawson wonders where residents personal
items the family mementos inside
each room fall on the risk spectrum
he says removing them should be done
with careful consideration
they take anything that they consider
non-non-essential to the health care
they move it out and they store it and
that becomes
not their space at that point and that
that's what's hard and it's hard
especially with people who have
dementia or cognitive issues person to
person transmission is still the primary
source of outbreaks
not these cuffs but extra precautions
will no doubt be taken
all the same nadia stewart global news
vancouver
in the u.s july proved to be an
especially difficult month in the fight
against covid19
there were nearly 2 million new cases of
the virus
and there are predictions that 180 000
americans could be dead
by the end of the summer this is the
harsh reality
and tonight one of the hardest hit
states dealing with a surge in cases
is also bracing for a major storm here's
jennifer johnson
for four days in a row this week florida
has hit a new coven 19 death record
now over 7 000 people have died from the
virus in that state alone
and there's a new concern tropical storm
isa is
dozens of state testing sites have been
forced to shut down
the entire east coast of florida is on
alert shelters are setting up physically
distancing barriers
and officials are taking other
precautions we have
the non-congregate options available for
people who may be
experiencing covid19 symptoms and a lot
of that will be
using hotels to be able to do that and
and that has been something that's been
prepared for
in california another milestone it has
become the first state in the u.s to
surpass 500 000 cases of covet 19
as the virus surges there too doctors
are still pleading with residents to
wear masks
if we don't get serious ashes ashes
we all fall down july turned into an
especially deadly month for the u.s with
covet 19 killing
another 25 thousand americans texas
recorded the most test last month
one doctor says they're fighting two
battles awards
against kavith and a war against
stupidity the first one
i have some hope about winning but the
second one is
is becoming more and more difficult to
trade
the centers for disease control expects
another 20 thousand people could die
from the virus in the next two to three
weeks
a grim prediction as schools and
colleges start to reopen
some parents in hard hit arizona are
being asked to sign covid liability
waivers
many teachers are choosing retirement
over returning
i love those kids and and where i taught
and what i did
but i'm not quite willing to die for
them
adding to the problems a stalled
economic relief bill in congress
pandemic unemployment benefits ran out
for close to 30 million people friday
more stress and uncertainty as americans
see no end to this crisis
jennifer johnson global news washington
mexico now has the third highest cover
19 death toll
after the u.s and brazil the virus has
killed nearly 47
000 people in mexico the country's
mortality rate
almost triples the global average the
government says three quarters of the
dead had
underlying health conditions mexico's
president continues to deny the benefits
of face masks
telling reporters he'll wear one when
mexico has no corruption
in south korea the leader of a secretive
church has been arrested for allegedly
hiding crucial information
from contact tracers lee man he has a
fringe christian sect that is at the
center of an
outbreak in that country involving more
than 5 000 cases
he's accused of hiding details on
members and their meeting places
the 89 year old is also accused of
embezzling 5.6
billion dollars in church funds
prime minister justin trudeau was forced
to confront the we charity controversy
head on this week when he testified
before the finance committee about his
ties to the organization and its
founders
farah nasser is guest hosting the west
block this week pharah
you spoke with the opposition leader
about this and what did andrew scheer
have to say
hi robin it's been another busy summer
week in federal politics with the we
charity controversy burning up more
oxygen for the liberals on thursday the
prime minister was grilled for over an
hour by members of the opposition
this week on the west block we're
speaking with andrew scheer the leader
of canada's official opposition
he's been grilling the prime minister on
the we charity controversy for days as
of some conservative mps shear is
accusing justin trudeau of sidelining
parliament
but the liberals aren't the only ones
who have been accused of that
i ask sheer what he thinks about the
fact former prime minister stephen
harper was criticized about shutting
parliament
take a listen you know you've criticized
the prime minister for sidelining
parliament but you're a party's former
leader former prime minister stephen
harper pro-rolled parliament four times
so isn't this type of criticism a bit
rich
not at all you know prorogation is done
at the provincial level at the federal
level regularly
it's a normal part of the parliamentary
cycle what justin trudeau has done
has effectively sidelined parliament in
the middle of a pandemic since march you
know there's a lot of reasons why
parliament needs to be saying there's
absolutely no comparison at all
to a normal parliamentary cycle that may
have been done
in the past canada's brand new
ambassador to the united nations bob ray
joins me on the show too just days
before he begins his new role
we'll ask the former interim liberal
leader if the government
should have seen this controversy coming
also today marks 600 days
since china imprisoned the two michaels
ray says he rejects calls to free
mangwon joe
and end the extradition process we're
dealing with a country that has
obviously taken huge exception
uh to the uh decision by canada to
respect our extradition treaty and
i think most people again feel quite
strongly that we have a treaty with the
united states as we do with a number of
other countries
um and we're not in a position to to
fool around with that treaty
i'll also be asking the new ambassador
about some of the frank opinions he's
voiced about donald trump in the past
all that and much more on the west block
robin all right thanks for that far and
you can watch the west block right here
on global
tomorrow morning celebrating the end of
slavery
coming up how emancipation day was
marked in one canadian city plus an nhl
game
like no other one player's powerful
speech about racism
there are marches across the country for
the annual celebration of emancipation
day
marking the abolition of slavery in
canada over 180 years ago
demonstrators called for an end to
ongoing anti-black racism and
racial violence by police the march
comes amid months of anti-racism
protests around the world
ignited by police killings of black
people in the u.s
an nhl player is getting support for his
anti-racism message as the hockey season
restarts racism is a man-made creation
hockey is a great game but it could be a
whole lot greater
and it starts with all of us matt dumba
is from regina and now plays for the
minnesota wild
he took a knee during the american
anthem the two teams then faced off in
their first game of a shortened season
two hub cities toronto and edmonton are
playing host to the nhl
the teams are going straight to
qualifying rounds for the stanley cup
playoffs
of course no crowds were present because
of pandemic restrictions
as we mentioned earlier in the newscast
florida which is struggling to contain
covet 19
is sitting in the crosshairs of tropical
storm issa east
it could become a hurricane again when
it hits the state's east coast
so now everyone should be safely at
staying at home
do not go out unless you really need to
as always with these storms
power outages are inevitable two
thousand workers from ten other states
have been brought in to help restore
electricity
the hurricane already blasted through
the bahamas and cuba
causing floods and damaging buildings
about 200 homes have been evacuated in
southern california
after the apple fire ignited near the
cherry valley community
the wildfire started on friday evening
and has scorched nearly
800 hectares since it began so far
no injuries have been reported the blaze
is one of several fires being fought
around southern california
as the region deals with a
record-breaking heat wave
amid natural disasters and a pandemic
the u.s president is waging a new war
with china over a video sharing app
donald trump is threatening to ban
tick-tock from the u.s
up to 80 million americans use the
chinese-owned app
per month tick-tock has denied
accusations that it's controlled by
or shares data with the chinese
government trump hasn't said when
or how he'll enforce the ban
breakthrough therapy is still ahead the
new drug therapies in canada for covid19
it's been five months since canada
reported its first case of cobit 19.
we're far from a cure but potential
treatments have been developed at record
speeds
heather yorick's west looks at the
promising drug therapies underway
across the country in the race to find
new therapies to fight the novel
coronavirus
one of the biggest breakthroughs came
when scientists in england discover that
a cheap and readily available steroid
drug
could effectively treat patients with
covid19 prior to the last few weeks you
might have only had maybe about 50
percent of doctors that were using
steroids in patients with
severe covet lung injury now i'd say
almost 100 percent of doctors are using
steroids in this population
dexamethasone doesn't target the virus
itself
rather it works to treat inflammation
caused by covid19
in a large clinical trial the drug was
found to help prevent one
death in every eight coven 19 patients
on ventilators
so the dexamethasone right now is
the therapy that i would say would be
leading in terms of its
benefit to patients and then the next
one that i mentioned was the rem
deserver which is the drugs
that specifically targets the
coronavirus itself
the anti-viral drug has shown promise in
clinical trials both in shortening the
duration of illness and reducing
mortality
but the drug was only recently approved
for use in canada
at the beginning of the pandemic you
know we were using it on a special
access
permit but it took many days to obtain
so it really wasn't practical
meanwhile another therapy that received
considerable buzz
early in the pandemic thanks to
endorsements from the u.s president
failed to deliver results when examined
in clinical trials
i think everybody is pretty convinced
that hydroxychloroquine does not work
for kova 19 and uh we were never using
it
here outside of clinical trials but
nowhere
i think is using that even anecdotally
now of course none of the new therapies
are considered cures by any stretch
but when compared to what was available
to physicians just
six months ago it's clear that in a very
short period of time
the way this new illness can be treated
has come a long way
heather urex west global news calgary
up next the self-described geek who
thinks this robot is the answer to those
dreaded zoom calls
the flag's all yours it's been a
pressure
astronauts doug hurley and bob bankin
were awarded one of the international
space station's
american flags today as they prepare to
leave the station
ending an historic mission by spacex two
months ago the astronauts held the first
ever launch of a manned
private spacecraft as well as the first
manned launch from u.s soil
in nearly a decade they're expected to
be back on earth
tomorrow the pandemic has forced
all of us to find new ways to stay
connected with loved ones
but a skype or zoom call isn't quite the
same as a chat
face to face and that got one british
toy designer thinking
as redmond shannon explains he's come up
with a cheap and safe way to transport
yourself
into someone else's home
ross atkin is a proud geek a design
consultant who's never stopped being the
kid
obsessed by lego yeah i feel like the
first job i got in design i was like
really they're going to pay me to
design stuff and you know build models
and do cad and
illustrator and stuff like because i was
like i'd just do that you know
i'd do that i didn't do that anyway he's
been designing self-assembly robot toys
for five years
and when the whole world started zooming
each other during the pandemic
a thought occurred to him having a video
call is nothing like
being with someone because you're stuck
in this little
rectangle and you're completely
dependent on what they're doing with
their rectangle
so atkin very quickly designed this
a cardboard telepresence robot
using a simple smartphone app
large telepresence robots for offices
can cost
thousands of dollars atkins model funded
by a kickstarter campaign
costs about a hundred bucks and is more
about engaging
small kids than big clients being able
to just
leave um the grandparents or the in-laws
in the robot
to chase the toddler around themselves
without having to
follow him around holding the phone that
then meant both of us could do something
he could play and they could still
interact with him it's not a substitute
for babysitting but it does add a new
level of
interaction for kids of all sizes even
news reporters too
although i could have used a rear camera
atkin also designs products for people
with disabilities
he thinks larger versions could have
many applications beyond the pandemic
you can make some care tasks
a lot more convenient for the carer and
for the person being cared for
and you can end up with the carer being
able to spend more time caring for
the person because they aren't having to
travel being a tiny robot
is not quite face to face contact but as
we've all learned in 2020
technology and clever design can help us
feel that little bit
closer to our loved ones redmond shannon
global news
london and that is global national for
this saturday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
the town of indian head saskatchewan
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so please email your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you